this what started as a local non-profit
a decade ago is bringing smiles to
children in hospitals all across the
nation now and this week win-win is
celebrating its 10th anniversary so
joining us we have the founder my good
friend Jeff civilaco uh who I'm really
proud of for doing this I mean it's just
incredible what he's done with this
um and also one of the outstanding
performers who has been on the board
gives his time to win-win magician Tim
gableson thank you both for being here
to be here 10 years people 10 years I
know it feels like just uh yesterday
that I was begging you to join our board
oh my gosh and and it's come it's come
so far in that time yeah how did you
come up with this idea job yeah so I've
been performing my whole life since I
was a little kid and I started off the
first show I ever did was for a special
needs School in the Philadelphia area so
that's really how I I started performing
entertaining at 14 years old and I just
loved that it was so fulfilling that I
just kept performing hospitals senior
care facilities for the Uso any type of
Charity or non-profit performance I
could do and then when I turn
professional I continued doing that and
fortunately for whatever reason more
performers that I've met have wanted to
get involved and give back and next
thing I know we've got hundreds of
performers and 10 years later hospitals
all across the country Tim you're one of
them you you two met in a work release
program
you've been on the board too and you've
entertained children all over the place
what got you involved besides your
encounter with Jeff but it's all about
Chad right no uh when I first started
with uh with Jeff he had this idea of
doing this and ah I didn't really get it
I didn't understand it and then I
started doing a hospital show and it was
the most amazing experience I did one in
Minneapolis where I'm from and just oh
my word we're touching lives that I
didn't realize and then I'm like you
really have something here and then Jeff
being Jeff just has taken it to this now
10 years yeah and it's so awesome
because it's fulfilling for all the acts
that's why we come in is because because
it's Soul feeling it's like you you walk
out and you're like it's not about money
it literally is about a smile on a child
and it's like I I was a part of that I
was a party and it's done so much and
even the pandemic actually kind of
propelled the mission forward we really
did we started doing virtual Hospital
programs which opened up uh so many
hospitals we we started uh serving UMC
Children's Hospital right here in Las
Vegas we had nine hospitals going
pre-pandemic and now we serve 35 every
week yeah I want to give a shout out by
the way to Timmy downplaying his
involvement here this was a Las Vegas
based organization and Tim started doing
work in Minneapolis at Children's
Minnesota and we really started talking
but this could be more this could be
natural so Tim is really responsible for
that initial uh National Expansion so
well Minneapolis was the Second City
after Vegas so yeah and and before the
interview Tim said whatever you do don't
rush me through the last part because he
has something for us but then we got
about 30 seconds
it was my ration at one point
um I didn't even get okay for this but
I'm gonna do it anyway
um yeah are the sensors FCC gonna yes
possibly watch and you guys are just
gonna pretend you don't see anything oh
see I've noticed that uh sometimes we we
see things and uh yeah it's just a ball
but if we were to actually try to change
it I have a glass with me because I
think if we
um if we pause in life like we pause for
this win-win we can start to see things
a little bit differently oh come on
hello wow that's awesome
[Music]
thank you for having me this is so
awesome thank you both for the work
you've done with win-win for starting it
for for being a huge part of now it's
it's success as it moves forward I just
love what you guys are doing so thanks
Daniel appreciate it thank you all right
check out where can people learn more
about win-win hey the Telethon is
happening tomorrow winwin
entertainment.org register free 10 hour
online
10 a.m where is it being held at it's on
Zoom Show creator Studio Show creator
Studios we're streaming live from show
creators yeah all right the website
again real quick
winwinentertainment.org register love it
all right we'll be